[Applause]
bacon and eggs every morning
is that what you do every morning what's
your breakfast what do you want to know
hello's gonna lie to you for sure okay
he's 100 gonna lie to you
what do you want to hear half a
grapefruit and uh
i still got that chicken palm tonight
got the doggy bag i'm gonna heat up
uh breakfast lately has been eggs and
bacon of some sort but here's where i go
wrong
wait a minute can i just say one thing
before you go here's where i go wait
hold on
oh [ __ ] bacon is that where you go wrong
okay where do you go wrong
i go wrong with uh no matter if we go to
the health food store because my girl
tries to you know keep me healthy and
stuff like that yeah yeah
and i just went to the doctor got a
physical all that stuff so i'm trying to
improve it but where i go wrong doesn't
matter if it's good for your food or bad
for your food
i'm gonna eat too much of it yeah like
what would you guys say
is the normal serving
of an english muffin of english muffin
how many english muffins is the fact
that you think that's health food is
crazy
i'm just saying i'm just using it that's
the word muffin let's say toast
that's okay let's say spelt bread at the
[ __ ]
two slices two yeah you say two slices
yeah that's interesting
that's a viewpoint too sure yeah what
are you gonna do feels a bit excessive
two nah nah you can go two two is you
know you do two two's legit but like
you're you should be good at two yeah
well how many you have
like two sandwiches worth like so four
slices
now being serious two slices yeah slices
yes yeah
i don't yo i don't eat bread yo if you
want to get back in shape i get you okay
this is my dress everybody with the keto
and i know what's going on
what i'm doing we did it on our podcast
you know what to do
yeah i don't do very good things i know
what to do but no no this is this is a
this is
i'm like rembrandt i'm all for my own i
realized when we were talking on the
podcast
we went to art school we didn't do it
but here's the thing i think in the
spirit of your show
there's probably nothing more garbage
than the fat dude that loses
all the weight and then starts wearing
like the tight clothes and like really
showing yeah
yeah and really leaning into it that's a
garbage thing to do is it not
here's the thing in the spirit of your
show even if you gain all the weight
back
at one point in your life you have to
lose everything and then start dressing
like me
yeah i mean i want to see like skin and
your ripped jeans i'm going to tell you
there's
there's there's breakups the only thing
worser the only thing
sadder than being worse that's 870 for
you folks
[Laughter]
mr 870 we call them around uh are you
garbage.com
oh my god
i think i beat that on math to be honest
with that
[Laughter]
the only thing worse true if you got a
higher if you're a dude who got
higher in what is it english or whatever
english it was english yeah english and
you got higher english you're gay bro
that's 100 yeah i had higher math
yeah you got to have higher math dude
okay go on here's the thing the only
thing worse than being the fat guy is
being the fat guy that
just lost weight no it's not you do
because the way the face is
that's the fact that his brain is
what the [ __ ] are you talking wait hold
on the fact that let's i want to do this
because we did it on our patreon
you know what's funny is is you stung me
i listen
i i don't know why we're going this way
in the conversation
i'll entertain this for a little care
about you but i'm starting to switch
here to live
i was told i was going to come in and
have a good time no he gave you the seat
with
a picture of this kid oh my god um okay
go
go go i recently went to the doctor got
my physical i'm on i look like the boss
in monsters
i'm on a path now i'm extra i'm
exercising to a degree every day we're
pulling back so this
this is this is just conversation but
you really stung me you got
me hold on did you hear that sentence
i'm exercising
or something i'm exercising to a degree
every day
[Laughter]
my doctor said i should walk a half an
hour a day that's all i mean i don't
think i'm out there doing crosstalk yeah
you're going to walk the burger king i
don't want to misrepresent myself
i'm i'm i'm walking but i will say
there was a lot there was that turn of
like all right it's not really funny
anymore we're worried about stuff like
that
and you stung me with one maybe like
three months ago i said it would love i
hope i didn't say anything mean but
well here's i didn't know what you i you
i was i was you bugged me out cause like
you did it
so sincerely and like i was we were
doing a rooftop show
all right and and i was hosting and i
was standing in the corner i just looked
the person like literally you know i'm
in [ __ ] you know i'm hosting
the purple in the apartment below
banging on this side
they just heard your fee full thumb up
jurassic park downstairs i just got the
watershed
the water
um okay no but you walked up so i was
like in like the zone you know i was in
the zone
i was about to leave so i had to talk to
you at that and he walks out and he like
gingerly puts his hand on my shoulder
and he looks at me right now he goes
why'd you have to describe with more
food
[Laughter]
[Music]
there was a lot of steaks on the table
[Laughter]
just the way the cookie crumbled that
night you gave me a full
he gave me two entrees of advice um and
he like looked me right in the eye and
he's like are you okay
and i was like i think i was like sweat
i would i'm sweating now dude
i don't want to say anything i was on
like four edibles at the time so i
wasn't really sure what you were
alluding to
they were cheesesteak
i get my crab drinks in tears oh my god
yo
okay go go so fatty eats his weed yeah
you go to the weed guy here you're right
all right come on he's looking you in
the rib eye right
all right and he just said are you okay
and like he said it sincerely
and he's like you know things are
starting to happen now you have to take
care of yourself
and that meant a lot to me yes and i i
that was like right after that is when i
scheduled my doctor's appointment
i got insurance and all that stuff and
i'm on my way i'm in the middle of like
seven different appointments right now
you know what i mean it's amazing i went
got my chest x-ray my ekg was fine
all that kind of stuff i am pre-diabetic
yeah pre-pre-diabetic he keeps adding
more freeze on it and i don't even know
if that's medically yeah that's what he
said good news it's a little you know
just finding that a little bit
i said when he was going to doctor he
was petrified and i said dude the best
thing come out of this
is like a little bit of a skit like i'm
like i don't if they come back and say
you're the healthiest guy i've ever met
in my life
the governor's off and you're going to
be dead in a month like you're right you
need to get checked and scared
to change your behavior and it i think
it has it's all very nice
quit yeah what's crazy is nicotine
actually is a thermogenic it helps you
lose weight which is hilarious that's
why i take it
but he now eats he now chews the gum so
he also eats the cigarettes too he quit
smoking him and now he eats them
he just takes an ash tray parliament's
in a little mustard not too bad
what i said to you and i mean this is
everything you were how did this turn on
neil you brought it up
i did not bring it out yes he did yeah i
said the second we had to get another
you asked me if
i was scared because yeah yeah no you
i would never have brought this
intervention
that's what this was that's what it was
yeah these cameras even on
well i brought up all you garbages like
you have this incredible thing
everything you
work for is about to come true right and
this is going to be the best time the
way up is the best
i'm worried you're not going to get to
enjoy it fully if you're overweight
um and when you said that i took it to
heart because you called me
yeah he was like dude akash got like it
[ __ ] shook him to the core yeah i
said it would love i
don't know and i i'm sorry i was like
thinking about like i can't come down on
this game
of course you did and i really
appreciate it there was one there was
you know a couple of instances i think i
texted you beforehand like is he gained
weight or he did yeah
yeah yeah because you texted me yo he's
texting me about him and then he
he was like said something to me last
night i was like i get it dawg i get why
a pandemic makes anybody
giving away frozen pizzas at the trade
fair i'm a [ __ ] human being over here
the point is i care about people's trade
fair
it's my great vocal grocery store oh i
thought that's like where you learn how
to like be a carpenter
chi institute or something he thought he
was multitasking i was working on a
two-stroke motor and
now so yeah it's it's the way i see it
it's it's it's behind us we're moving
forward and we're done
and i didn't take it anything but with
love and anybody who said anything
i i haven't taken a anything but with
love
yeah but then there gets it to this like
annoying point where you're like people
are trying to give me like life advice
oh yeah it is there because you know it
is there because you know this thing
it's not like they're telling you
something
that's what i'm saying i know how many
english muffins you're supposed to have
here's the thing
he runs out of breath in simple
sentences it also is selfish on our part
because like
as your friend you feel like you got to
say it because if you don't you're an
[ __ ] yeah but it's really the salad
fork you guys want to make yourselves
feel better well it's also
the waiter at the restaurant no that's
what i'm saying what i'm saying is like
if i don't say anything to you i got to
get it off my chest yeah
you got to clear your conscience i'm
going to clear myself at the funeral you
could be like one night yeah i did my
baby
on the show i tried to talk to him
you're fat
we're good that's it that's it say it
right into the camera
it is weird but i do think there's part
of it no 100 any friend i've had who
struggle with like substances or
whatever i've been like y'all
i if i don't say something something
happens this guy it's on you yeah yeah
it's a selfish
it's a selfish motive for sure i'll tell
you this it worked i quit smoking
i'm walking around the track with my
girl almost every day and we've reduced
what we ate and it's just gonna take a
little bit of time and it's gonna it's
gonna be great
yeah you got this yeah i'm like we do
lunch here
can we order in what's going on you guys
got a jimmy john's close by you can talk
to him
all right boys so what else what is next
what happens with the pod what are you
guys dreams about it like
i don't know i'm curious about it we
just uh we took it i took a page right
out of i talked to you about it
come on we're team schultzy the whole
way yeah where we because we built like
so we made a set it's a great great we
rented a studio we rented a space in
midtown turned into a studio
all in like [ __ ] four days like wild
so we didn't miss any episodes
i mean it looks like a basement we put
up like wood paneling it looks like your
[ __ ] aunt's basement or whatever
i
a lot of the [ __ ] is from his house like
we went back to our parents house and
like
got all these old [ __ ] tchotchkes and
[ __ ] he's got his football jersey
hanging up on the wall and like frame
old number 62. what's up tchotchke is
like a white guy thing for a knickknack
there's a knickknack still kind of like
the office space that's why
yeah how many keys you got on yeah yeah
yeah yeah for that slayer pieces of
flare the restaurant
yeah it was pieces of flair yeah so yes
you guys got this great studio so we
built the studio
uh toby's producer toby's producing it
came in
the video quality is [ __ ] we're like
running it's cool because it's like
there's three of us and one of them's
him so there's two of us
yeah uh and we're really [ __ ] just
like running and gunning it's exciting
we're growing every [ __ ] week
yeah you know youtube's been really good
for you guys youtube's been great
uh yeah man we're literally just
following the [ __ ] schultzy moment as
you should
text them as things like as i'm like
making it i'm like hey how about this
he's like that seems right to me i'm
like
well chelsea said it we're doing it well
anything you guys need we are here for
you man any way we can help
i i think it's just so great but if
there's one piece of advice
that i would give you and i've given you
a million times i'm not going to say it
anymore unless you do it
it's making a 10 episode of this it's
just the highlights
just take the are you garbage section
i'm telling you that explodes that's
that's the next thing we're just [ __ ]
production like every person that comes
out with a movie
will want to do that little 10-minute
thing it just separates it it feels like
its own show and then you get a sponsor
for that
i said hefty will sponsor it yeah like
if i'm a garbage talking to you
literally if you're a garbage bag
company would you not well it's funny
they do advertise like youtube puts
hefty commercials in front of the
[ __ ]
in front of the show they know what
they're doing no but also they don't
they just see the word garbage garbage
yeah
they're youtubing garbage yeah also the
people that are watching our show aren't
buying name brand [ __ ] trash bags
you know what i mean they're fun they're
using like the shopping bag yeah
the bag from the grocery store and like
hooked it around like a knob or
something
yeah and push it in and that's the trash
bag definitely garbage
yeah i need it that's a big new york
thing though i need to see this
you told me and when after your episode
came out you texted me you're like
dude do cut it at a 10-minute version
it's like yeah i mean i just
i mean at that point i was doing all the
production i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing call toby we'll have a call
with toby but i want lights changed i
want to be dramatic
toby's already got a laundry list and
[ __ ] he's going to love a phone call
with more responsibility
he wants to be a millionaire yes but
bust out cigarettes like you guys got to
get into character a little bit like
what would be the most garbage thing to
do like drink
like a diet dr pepper yeah you're a big
doctor pepper guys
he's a big dr pepper guys mr pig is
garbage dr pepper is classic
the trashy soda is a is a cherry vanilla
diet dr
pepper that is the official beverage of
the garbage nation
any brand any version of mountain
there's some storage or any of those no
it's got to be a diet because that's the
trashier thing
you're drinking breaking news you're
drinking regular soda like that
you're owning yourself dr pepper buddy
it's a doctor okay it's got a degree
it's designed it's the diet that makes
it dry and it's bottled in texas these
are two things very
texas people we found out texas people
are die hard dr pepper [ __ ] with
anything like they don't [ __ ] with
anything else
it's like yo we're a doctor pepper
fountain like through and through
bloodline generations dr pepper it's
[ __ ] wild it's like a part of the
culture there it's it's weird
we're comparing they're standing on the
flag for dr pepper
we're throwing batteries at people
that's why we're trash
yo i'll be coming here with that mr
pibbs and [ __ ]
you